what is going on there citizens the
reject Nation we admitted to the final
episode of tales of the Jedi they have
all been great of course joined by
Michael burrito today
Michael
Omni media
you looking forward to this you ready to
cry
we'll see we'll see I am looking forward
to it not we'll see that we'll see if I
cry gotta close actually a few times
Well if you don't cry then you're you're
not giving a real reaction
it's the mark of true reacting
use the force to leave a like hey follow
Michael on his YouTube channel he's got
a great reaction Channel and also uh
full length watch songs will be single
they don't copy for Tales the Jedi
available at our patreon page thank you
all have joined let's get to it
it's like poetry
like a little George Lucas appear behind
like poetry
uh we're gonna have our own little joke
here man
beautiful
I swear if I hear that in my head The
Next Star Wars show I'm I'm gonna let
you know
I recognize them legs I know those feet
yeah
[Music]
you're right on time oh really I thought
it was late that's what I meant I was so
cool
I really wouldn't know
foreign
just thinking about Obi-Wan yeah yeah
where he's like in that
chamber
in The Inquisitor basement
[Music]
so cool
uh so cool oh wait
[Music]
was that um was that Caleb Caleb what he
was Caleb are we overthinking that
I'm just wondering if that is
it'll never cover thanks for coming
master
well I was in the area
any thoughts
you don't want to know
right keeper striving for that approval
get her with that emotional abuse early
what's the problem
yeah yeah it is yeah it's a lousy test
but it's what every Jedi does
exactly
we'll test
name it
practice makes perfect
but there's no such thing as perfection
definitely not with Anakin
foreign
I'm Gonna Get You So Many hate comments
with that
sorry
stays in the video you're right on time
I thought I was late that's what I mean
[Music]
because that's what Obi-Wan said
[Laughter]
Rex Captain Rex and the boys have agreed
to help with the test the privilege
Commando you will have to fight this
battalion
no oh Jesus wait droids are predictable
I want you to be prepared for anything
wow this is costing uh the Republic a
lot of money should be able to sense the
moment before they even pull the trigger
not bad don't worry she'll wake up wake
up
that's it come on you'll be used to it
wake up
I don't think you should get used to it
how long was I out an hour an hour yeah
Jesse really tagged you oh Jesse
you ready
begin
okay God Jesus
this is a super harsh discipline
[Music]
no defeat in this dojo
oh my God this must be so boring for the
clone troopers
wait around an hour oh my god dude again
again
[Music]
this is so meat this is messed up man I
half expected I'm just paying back and
just they're they're just shooting her
while she's unconscious
I don't know how much love this she can
take
she'll be fine
well you're waking up faster
[Laughter]
the droids aren't half as good as Rex's
men that's the point
exactly look I know this is tough but
this
is about life and death
the best way I can protect you is to
teach you how to protect yourself oh my
God you're her mom you ready for
anything on a battlefield well yeah
anything with a blaster at least
maybe we should have told her why
earlier yeah
all right boys let's go again
really was like a parent yeah
uh so you're so cool
did she kill all them
oh
not bad it took us five minutes to knock
you out that time
we don't have the run time for that
[Laughter]
this is so cool yeah she's like well
there's like nunchucks oh
I love how we're like we skipped ahead
to just kind of see her progress to from
where they last when they started the
whole thing oh
is this from the final
episodes
yeah yeah
holy [ __ ] wow
holy [ __ ] hang on we have time to win
the command and all remaining troops in
my position
[Music]
why they choose to go to that moment
go back
I mean we know what happens but still
holy crap that was interesting why I
really want why they huh why that moment
specifically
no but you get I mean it's a big fight
she survives the entire thing though and
that's the thing because I think that's
the longest Contin like contiguous
battle she actually has to like ah and
so the get through the training then
paid off for that and that's what that's
what Rex was referring to when he said
that I was like oh you did you lasted
five minutes this time it's like well
this time
you're gonna have to do way more than
five minutes
wow it is there's like a nice payoff and
reward when you you're watching this
because like a big Intrigue is like kind
of going back to the Clone Wars times
you know even though it's going before
Clone Wars but once you see all them
again you're like oh [ __ ] we're getting
like new content with them they're back
like that's awesome uh is it that is
exciting and and to see the
complementary factor it's there's
certain there's a certain kind of with
Jedi characters and then the way they've
handled Ahsoka story there's a there's a
certain kind of Destiny quality to to
them and the first episode kind of has
that Destiny quality and then here it
really it really kind of solidifies that
Anakin was the teacher she was always
meant to have you know unless you it
needed exactly to survive yeah in the
end exactly exactly oh
that's cool that's really cool I thought
that was great connected back to yeah I
love how it connected back to that first
one too
it's like a how the the life and death
theme exactly carried on
uh
it's so good to see them all again too
I know man just the little quips here
and there and then just like the just
the little little small moments of how
like the teachers influence their
students like that one little thing
where he showed up late he's like oh
you're just still in time it's like Oh I
thought it was late well that's the
point yeah and then he Echoes the same
thing to Ahsoka when she's late
and just like there's little things oh I
forgot that um
because you see you see Caleb at the
beginning of um
when did he go by because there's a
Canaan and Rebels you see Caleb at the
beginning of uh bad batch the first
episode yeah with uh when depa dies yeah
and see them both there I'm just playing
yeah I think I'm pretty sure it's uh it
must be the same okay I think it's the
same kid yeah yeah when the
if I remember right I think he just goes
by Kanan once when he's in hiding like
just you know that makes guards the name
yeah
all right well damn that was that was
cool
it's funny having that like when you
first see her training
with those with those droids or whatever
that type of do you know the name of
that because that's what I thought they
always trained I don't I don't know the
name of that I just I don't know that
there's probably some actual designation
but I just always call them the training
droids or whatever it's just like the
same thing Luke used in
yeah A New Hope but whenever we see them
I'm always like oh there they are again
yeah and then Anakin had that thought
process and I was like ah this is lame
I'm glad you said that man because yeah
it's just like that's how they always
train all right that's great we only got
one more left but uh we we shot up to it
I thought that was awesome all right
let's let's check out this next one
do it
guys leave a like subscribe and uh hey
Paul Michael B
all right let's get going
[Music]